I see how you someway avoid to kill
someone people asked me you know how do
you do the interviews and how do you
keep your temper suppose closest I've
ever come to wanting to kill someone was
in India mum we were doing story about a
child prostitution people young people
young girls being stolen from their
families been taken away chained to beds
for over a year where they're they're
raped and eventually they can't leave
that place they don't know the way back
and also they're a shame to their family
so they can't go back anyway I met mr.
Khanna it's not his real name who
specialized when he was younger
in entrapment in trapping these girls on
a one-to-one saying that he married them
you know he'd come in on a scooter which
is something that most those people
don't aspire to ever owning he'd ride
the girl around promised to take it to
his family then he drugged them and then
sell them on to to a brothel mr. Khan
has around about three hundred four
hundred people working for him
he traffics around 1,200 to 1,300 girls
every year and we knew that he had been
responsible for killing some of them but
when I asked him how many he believed
he'd killed he told me that he killed he
couldn't remember exactly between 300
and 400 girls either by strangulation by
stabbing them or by poisoning them and
when he told me my translator who was
obviously hearing what he was speaking
first started to cry when I heard the
translation through her sobs he started
crying now I've met some very bad people
and most of them are victim of
circumstance but when he started feeling
sorry for himself for the fact that he
killed those young girls I see only some
way avoid to kill someone